[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON QUEK: Hi, everybody.
My name is Jason Quek.
And welcome to my
breakout session
on using machine learning to
meet general data protection
regulations.
So just a brief
introduction of myself.
I work as the lead cloud
architect in Avalon Solutions.
We are a premier partner
of Google globally.
And our headquarters
is in Sweden.
Our specialties are within
GCP are in infrastructure lift
and shift.
We do machine projects as well.
And we also help the customers
get the best of their Google
Suite experience.
Now in the brief session, I'm
going to cover a few topics.
So what is GDPR?
And who does this affect?
To understand GDPR,
we have to understand
as well what is personal data.
Then we're going to talk
about the protections given
by GDPR to EU citizens.
And next, we're going to
go through a few use cases
and how to use machine learning
to provide those protections.
So what is GDPR?
GDPR is a regulation
that protects
personal data of EU
citizens and the processing
and movement of data as well.
So this regulation actually goes
into force 25 May of this year.
As you might remember, from
the 23rd onwards of May,
there was many companies
sending you emails
with enhanced [INAUDIBLE]
conditions requesting
your consent to use your data
for their processing needs.
Now that's the first step to
GDPR is obtaining consent.
Who does this affect?
This affects any organization
that collects, stores,
and processes personal data.
And this is on
European citizens.
So it doesn't matter if
you are from a US company
or you are an Asian company.
You will have to comply with
these regulations as well.
And any noncompliance actually
comes with a very huge fine.
The fine can come to almost
a 4% of the annual revenue.
Now let's talk
about personal data.
So these are some
examples of personal data.
Things like your
name, your ID number,
or in the US, your
Social Security number,
your credit card number,
your email address.
Even your picture is
data that belongs to you.
Now you can see
it in many forms.
You can see it as structured
data in the database.
Or you can see it
as unstructured data
in your Google Docs, your
slides, or your spreadsheets,
and even in emails.
Think about it this way--
data, as we know it now
in GDPR, the companies
don't own your data anymore.
What you're doing,
you're actually
loaning your data to the
companies for them to use it.
And you have the
right to control
that data which you give them.
So this is what GDPR is about.
So what are the main protections
given by GDPR to EU citizens?
I'd like to use a
mnemonic here called
the big, red rhino
protects data.
So when you think about GDPR,
think of a big, red rhino.
The B stands for
breach notification.
R stands for right of access,
Right to be forgotten,
Privacy by design, as well
as Data protection officers.
Now let's break
down the problem.
As Avalon Solutions, we
have many, many services
that we build for customers.
And GDPR is approaching.
Also, we have systems in
GCP with data in Drive.
We have personal data in Drive.
We have personal data in
cloud storage buckets,
in [INAUDIBLE] buckets.
Now what we need to do next
is to create functionality
to allow a user to be forgotten
completely from systems.
To retrieve all related
information about a user,
if the user requests
for the information,
we need to build breach
notification capabilities.
And we also need to rethink our
systems with privacy in mind.
Now there's a lot of data
we're going to handle.
So we look at GCP, and
we look at the kind
of products they offer.
Things like Pub/Sub, so we
can handle large amounts
of data coming in.
We leverage App Engine.
To me, I love App Engine,
because you can fling up
great web interfaces
really quickly, which
is a very great way to get input
to train your machine learning
models.
We got to leverage face
recognition technology as well.
And we're going to use
of this open source
facial recognition models,
where we can use to detect
faces to fulfill the right.
We can look at the data
loss prevention API
as well, Google Drive APIs.
And we also use Big Query
and Stackdriver Logging.
So this is our strategy.
We're going to use
as much GCP products
as we can to builds those
protections on GDPR,
so that we can meet
the dateline of 25 May.
Let's jump into
breach notification.
What is a breach?
So when you build systems
on GCP, you build firewalls,
and you have the lowest
right and lowest permissions,
so people cannot
access the systems.
But how do you actually
detect a breach?
How do you know when your
system has been breached?
So one of the tactics
as well is using
machine learning to
detect locks, intrusions,
difficult patterns.
So one of our use cases,
we're actually using TCP dump,
and it's a very simple tool, to
lock all DNS calls from servers
and as well as all workstations.
And we pipe all these DNS
URL calls into Stackdriver.
And what's great about that
is Stackdriver is serverless.
So it can handle as much load
as you give it basically.
So it can also
handle this millions
of calls that can occur on a
server or on a workstation.
Now using a recurring
neural network with long,
short-term memory,
we can detect--
OK, I'll give you a
background of malware.
When malware attacks one
of your VMs, what it does
is it uses a domain
generation algorithm to try
to connect to a
common control server
to get further instructions.
To take the next step, you'd
have to destroy information
or to hold it ransom.
So this was one of the tactics
used by the Cryptolocker
ransomware in order to
get further instructions.
So for example, in
your Stackdriver logs,
if you see a domain name in
the bottom left corner there,
it means that your
system has been
attacked by the Cryptolocker
ransomware, and it's infected.
The source paper is over here.
So what we did was that
we had trained this model
using [INAUDIBLE] Engine.
And we provided two
sources of information.
So the first source was using
top 1 million websites that
were real from [INAUDIBLE]
and as well as using
a domain generation algorithms
that were cracked already
to generate large amounts of
training data of malicious DNS
URLs.
And what we do is that we're
training on [INAUDIBLE] engine.
And we also put it in
the cloud data store,
where you detect there
is possible breaches.
One thing about
ML models as well
is that you need constant
feedback in order
to continuously
improve your model.
So we also create a web
interface for DevOps guys
to go in and classify
any suspicious errors
as benign or malicious.
This is for probabilities
that are lower than, say, 60%.
So then we can actually
continuously update the model
and improve it.
We also make use of Cloud
Composer, which is basically
Apache Airflow, to continuously
train it once a week
so that it is updated
on-the-fly as we go along.
I'm going to jump to a quick
demo over here on my screen.
So for this case, we have
the malware DNS monitoring.
Click on it.
Pardon the Wi-Fi.
It's taking a while.
Sorry for that.
All these logs are actually
going into Stackdriver
right now.
And we have also locked the
resource names as well as
the probability of it
being malicious DNS calls.
And what the DevOps
guys can go in to do,
actually, is just tag it
as benign or malicious.
It's a very simple,
continuously-improving process.
So for example, let's
just type in some
addresses here to classify.
So you'd look at
google.com, for example.
There's a very low chance
of being malicious.
Let's take a long
address domain name just
to check [INAUDIBLE] length
they were talking about.
There's also a very low
chance of it occurring.
So if you take something that is
generated off domain generation
algorithm over here
for Cryptolocker,
you can see that's a higher
probability of being malicious.
So it's not just length.
It's also the placement of
the consonants within vowels.
And how we detect that by
using the neural network
to train it and get
the right detections.
So there's one way you can
use machine learning to detect
this malicious DNS URLs.
Can we go back to the slides?
Thanks.
So next, the right of access.
What is the right of access?
When a person goes
to your company
and say, give me all
the personal information
you have within
your systems to me,
with GDPR, you have to comply.
And then we talk about
how do you do it.
What do you use the data for.
And you actually have to
give all this data back
in a readable form.
How do you do that when all
your information is stored
in G-Suite and storage
buckets, and you don't have
enough metadata to understand?
How do you do it for pictures,
for maybe your company
photos when you go for outings?
What we built, actually,
we used Google Drive.
And we actually scanned through
all the files and Google Docs,
Google sheets, spreadsheets
every time it has been changed,
as well as PDFs and
image files, first
using Google Vision
APR that also
has OCR capabilities as well.
So even your credit
card number on a picture
is considered
personal data as well.
This is triggered using Google
Drive and Google Cloud Storage
push notifications.
They're pushed to Pub/Sub.
And then what we do is that
we push it to App Engine
as a call, which are called
APIs and try to figure out,
is this personal data or not?
To access this right,
users have to go and supply
their personal data to
search within the system.
So for example,
for me, I submitted
a photo of myself going from
left to right, top to bottom.
And then this is
used as a picture
to scan for all the image
files within Cloud Storage
as well as Google
Drive for me in it.
So when new images are saved
in the Google Drive and Cloud
Storage, they're actually first
scanned by Google Vision API,
so they can annotate
on the faces.
So we find the coordinates
whether this photo
has a face in it or not.
The reason is that we use
Google Vision API [INAUDIBLE]
handle method skill compared
to using our open face
models directly.
The reason for that
is, like I mentioned,
it's serverless as
well as much cheaper.
So when we detect there
is a face within an image,
and this image is not
only stored as JPEG,
but images that are
stored within a Google Doc
or within a Google slide,
they are embedded images
as well we are talking about.
When we detect there is a
face, we extract the face,
find the coordinates, crop
it out, and use OpenFace
to get the vectors of the face.
So your face becomes, basically,
a floating point number vector.
And we store it into BigQuery.
The reason we use
BigQuery is because it
allows us to search for these
images in a very good manner
and very fast manner as well.
So we search for the
lowest exceeding distance
between, say, my
face and others faces
stored within the systems.
So any measures above
a certain threshold
are then stored into
Cloud Datastore.
You can actually look at it from
the App Engine website as well.
I'm just going to
jump into a demo here.
You look at the
personal data search.
What I'm going to do is just
submit my face over here,
something I just
took earlier on.
So I get a search ID back.
So what it's doing now
is vectorizing my face.
Give it a few seconds.
What it's doing
in the background
is actually getting
my face data.
We actually run up OpenFace
as a container on GKE,
and then getting the
vectors out, and then doing
a query on BigQuery.
Let's refresh it.
Search completed.
So now, you can see that
I have some images on me
that I put on the
G-Suite system.
And then you can
actually have the link,
the owner of the images
of the document as well.
Of course, there
are a few others.
That is my son.
It's quite close,
but not close enough.
And some of my colleagues
over here in the bottom.
So what you do normally,
you do a threshold,
so you can find the closest
match to your faces.
And then you can deliver
it in a document.
So we can open a
document here as well.
[INAUDIBLE] slides.
You see some tests here.
And this is how you
look like in BigQuery.
Over here, you can see that
this is how your face looks
like as a vector.
Can you change
back to the slides?
Thanks.
So now, the right
to be forgotten.
So then we got to build the
next step, which is the right
to be forgotten by a user.
So for example, if a person
answers the question to a quiz
and you store it
using Google Forms,
you store it in a spreadsheet.
After you have entered the
quiz and you got a prize,
you actually can request
to get your data removed
from the system, so that you
can prevent direct marketing.
And the user organization
actually have to comply.
Because it is within your rights
to remove that information.
However, the company may
have use for that information
as well.
You want to keep track of
maybe the answer that you give.
So even though your
name identifies you,
maybe the answer that
you gave to the question
does not identify you.
So that doesn't fall within
the scope of personal data.
So when a person submits
a request to be forgotten,
the DPO will actually go using
the App Engine web interface
to do a request
for access to get
all the hits you get back on
your G-Suite and your buckets.
And what the DPO does
is that it will then
make a few steps to
remove the whole document.
In G-Suite as well, there's
version handling as well.
For every single
document you have,
every single spreadsheet,
every single slide,
there is versioning, which
means that if you just
remove the picture on the
latest version and you save it,
what you can do,
you can actually
go back to the previous
version very easily
and get back the
pictures again, which
means that you have not really
removed all your personal data
from the system.
And that's something
that's is kind of a catch.
So one possible way is to
remove the whole document if you
don't need the information.
Next step is to remove
the relevant information.
Now this is quite a
troublesome procedure.
Because what you need to do is
recreate the entire document,
removing the personal data.
So now, we have automated that.
So it actually recreates
the entire document,
but without the
personal information
that the user has requested
for to be removed.
Or you can replace the
information with dummy data.
Or you maybe remove the
sentence or the row.
So there's a few calls,
a decision-making process
here that the DPO has
to do to actually take.
Now what we use for
training and model is
we want to imitate the DPO and
try to see what kind of factors
does he take into consideration
to execute the next steps.
So we look at features such
as number of words in a file.
If it's a large file, you cannot
remove the whole entire file.
Because you may need certain
information from the file
as well.
So that is a consideration.
When it was last modified?
If it's a very old file, maybe
you don't need it anymore.
The type of personal
information-- is it a picture?
Is your face in the picture?
Maybe it doesn't make sense
to put a right triangle
in a picture and
reupload it again,
covering one person's face.
Maybe just remove the
entire picture directly.
The access rights of the file--
who has access to these files?
So it's only one person that
has already left the company,
then you can just
remove the document.
The location of the
file-- so what we did
was restructure the
entire G-suite layout
as well, so that the
location of the file
determines and
dictates where you
keep different kinds of
personal information.
So the DPO will make a
decision and then that
is trained to this ML model.
And this ML model is a
very, very simple model.
It's just a linear
classifier to give you
whether it should
be removed, or it
should be redacted, or
replaced with dummy data.
So what happens is that the
model will make suggestions
through the web interface.
And then life becomes
easier for DPO.
And right now, we don't have
enough data to actually make
this decision automatically.
So what we're doing now is
just running a few scenarios
to generate train data,
so that we can eventually
automate the system.
So when it comes to invoking
the right to be forgotten,
you can just invoke it,
and we can make a decision.
Someone has just confirmed it.
And you can remove all
these documents away.
So I'm now going to jump
into privacy by design.
With Google Suite and
Google Cloud Storage,
one of the awesome things
you can do is share files.
You can share files.
You can share by links.
You can add people
in the groups.
But with privacy by
design, what that means to
us is that you have to think of
privacy at the highest level.
Because when you think about
someone loaning you their data,
that means you're
responsible for it.
You have to make
sure that you don't
share data
irresponsibly and cause
a problem to your company.
So any changes in access rights
of file with personal data
should be investigated.
You mentioned one of
the previous tasks
was identifying any
documents with personal data.
So that is done.
Now how do you understand which
is a dangerous access right
change?
How do you do that?
To get any change in
terms of access changes,
we use the same driver again.
They have inbuilt
logging of any changes
to cloud storage
objects, which is great.
And then this is
published into Pub/Sub.
It flows so well together
that it just took us
one day to implement this.
It's so fast.
And using Google Drive,
you can subscribe
to push notifications as well.
So every time there's
a permission change,
it also updates you and
tell you, OK, this document
has been shared with somebody.
So again, we pipe it through
Pub/Sub into App Engine.
And we also train the model.
And the model detects
whether the access right
change is correct or not.
In this case, it's binary only.
Some of the features
that we use,
we use who do you
share the files to.
For example, in GCS,
you can share objects
into a service account, or you
can share to a group of users.
So if you're sharing
to a group of users,
it means that you can do that.
But is that an access
right violation?
If you share personal
data to a group,
you better do it carefully.
The location of the
file, like I mentioned,
we restructured
our file storage,
so that we can put personal
data in the correct places.
The job title and
department of the user,
we found that quite
useful as well.
For example, the
marketing department
doesn't have to have access to
the CVs that HR have, right?
But the manager of
marketing department
may need access to the CVs.
So we found that's quite
interesting feature
that we use as well, as well
as the current permissions
the user has.
So with that, we just train
a linear regression model.
And it comes back and tags any
changes in the access rights
as possibly correct
or incorrect.
DevOps can go in and monitor
these access right changes
as well.
And if you see a large amount
of access changes being made,
it can also detect that and flag
that as a possible violation.
The last thing I
want to talk about
is the data protection officer.
GCP is a data processor.
The company using the GCP
is the data controller,
which, in this case, is
us, Avalon Solutions.
What everything a
company need to do,
you need to designate a
data protection officer that
basically handles all
issues with personal data
and the protection
of personal data.
So this means that the DPO
can be very, very busy.
They have to train their
users as well where
to store the personal data.
I mentioned there is
locations of where
you should store your
personal data, in which file,
in which directory.
And also, to answer
some questions
on GDPR and some
company-specific questions.
So for this, we use Dialogflow
to build a chat bot,
so that our employees can go
in and ask questions about GDPR
and whether is this
personal data or not.
So a few examples we
got is, for example, we
run Kubernetes workshops.
You can go into the
DPO chat bot and ask,
where should I save the sign
up list, the spreadsheet?
Even though you
train your people
about where to save personal
data, you can also, on the fly,
ask the DPO chat bot.
Say, you should save
it into this directory.
You should only share it to
this person and this group,
so that you don't
accidentally leak out
your usernames or
your email addresses.
Another question we often
get from our employees
is, is a username
considered personal data?
And then we also have many
discussions about that.
So we can answer to you as well
that pseudo-anonymous data is
actually considered
personal data as well.
Because it can be linked
back from a Google search.
Because a lot of people
use their usernames
in many of different platforms.
So we could trace back to, say,
Facebook or any social media
profiles and leaking
their true identity.
So this is considered
personal data as well.
In conclusion, what
I'm trying to show
you is that the GDPR things
that we did, when we use
AI to solve it, it
was kind of like you
think about it, who wants to
[INAUDIBLE] compliance right.
It's kind of a dry topic.
But we have found a way to use
some of the latest technologies
in Google Cloud and in the
world to spice things up,
so we can learn
things on the fly
as well, learn machine learning
as well as we go along,
and to test whether
does it actually work.
And the best way to
understand whether it works
is by using it.
So we see that it does benefit.
We do save a lot of time
classifying this information
and tracking this potentially
harmful violations.
And so that we can go out
and build other cool stuff.
That's all I have.
My email address is here--
jason.quek@avalonsolutions.com.
So if you have any questions,
feel free to drop me a email.
And we can discuss
a bit more about how
we built some of these
solutions and things you have
to think about to make sure that
your organization is protected
in GDPR.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]